y
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
nos acompaña el presidente de armenia
armenia oficial
señor presidente muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros desde ereván en
armenia
es un placer hablar con ustedes
stephanie hay una guerra en nagorno
karabaj un enclave azerbaiyano y su
mayoría poblado por armenios una guerra
entre azerbaiyán y su país armenia señor
presidente su país y azerbaiyán a cortar
un nuevo alto el fuego el sábado en la
noche como intento el alto el fuego fue
violado una vez más porque
tengo una pregunta para mis colegas
acerías para las autoridades de
azerbaiyán no para el a dormir
la primera pregunta es porque el 27 de
septiembre azerbaiyán inició la guerra
contra la república de arzak contra las
personas de nagorno karabaj
por supuesto armenia como república y
los armenios de todo el mundo
incluyendo a los armenios que viven en
francia apoyan a nagorno karabaj
la pregunta es qué pasa con los más de
20 años del proceso de paz que han sido
liderados por el grupo de minsk de la
osce fue presidido por francia eeuu y
rusia
esas negociaciones se han llevado a cabo
durante más de 20 años y han sido
bastante exitosas en el momento en el
que hay un asunto tan complejo hay
cientos y cientos de preguntas el
proceso de minsk las ha reducido y ha
resuelto de manera exitosa varios
problemas ha creado una especie de
confianza y eventualmente estuvo cerca
de resolver algunas preguntas que eran
los más importantes y había preguntas
que necesitaban una voluntad y un
compromiso políticos
pero el 27 de septiembre azerbaiyán
inició una guerra como usted sabe
después de un tiempo rusia me dio un
alto el fuego y el lado hacer y rompió
ese alto el fuego creo que es más una
pregunta para el lado hacer y porque
iniciaron la guerra y porque rompieron
el alto el fuego el alto el fuego y el
inicio de la guerra empezaron con el
bombardeo de este para que la ciudad
capital de la república de alsac la
tercera vez hasta donde sé
creo que el lado francés y los
copresidentes también estaban
involucrados para establecer un alto el
fuego estable pero azerbaiyán lo volvió
a violar
parece que creen que pueden resolver el
conflicto con una guerra en vez de una
discusión
bento quin señor presidente el ministro
de defensa de azerbaiyán acusó a armenia
de utilizar armas para atacar las
posiciones del ejército azerbaiyano en
dos regiones en el norte de nagorno
karabaj a lo largo de la frontera que
piensa sobre esto señor presidente
no estoy en una posición para
contestarle al ministro de defensa
creo que está en lo correcto
puede preguntarle a mi ministro de
defensa o al ministro de defensa de la
república de saja
turquía y azerbaiyán niegan que turquía
haya enviado dejaditas sirios a nagorno
karabaj a usted dice que sí lo hicieron
tiene pruebas señor presidente
no creo que preguntarle a un presidente
de la república por pruebas sea lo
correcto primero segunda la prueba está
ahí
los combatientes están ahí y no sólo no
mejor no escarabajo estos combatientes
estuvieron en silla estos combatientes
estuvieron en libia ahora esa misma
agencia turca los trajo a azerbaiyán la
prueba está ahí la diferencia entre
ahora y la primera guerra que fue a
principios de los 90 es que había unos
combatientes yihadistas de afganistán y
de otras partes pero era algo
individuales
esta vez estos combatientes o
terroristas son grupos terroristas
prohibidos por muchos países incluidos
francia están ahora en el territorio de
azerbaiyán combatiendo contra los
armenios en arzak organizados por
turquía no necesito tener pruebas porque
varias agencias en varios estados e
inteligencia de los estados unidades o
departamentos de inteligencia de estados
específicos incluyendo a la federación
rusa el líder ruso de la inteligencia
extranjera lo han confirmado en vídeos
fotos grabaciones de audio si más no se
trata de demostrarlo o no demostrarlo
cuando el lado a ser igual lado turco
empieza a hablar de pruebas se me
recuerda algo distinto y es que a
turquía le gusta hablar pero hay una
prueba de que un millón y medio de
armenios fueron asesinados a 605 años en
un genocidio armenio 200 cuando un
millón y medio de personas fueron
masacradas y hubo un genocidio
hablar ahora de una prueba de cada
familia y decirles que traigan una
prueba de que estuvieron ahí y que los
mataron no es lo que debemos pensar esto
debemos pensar en las pruebas porque
están ahí sino en la presencia turca y
básicamente en que turquía está
combatiendo junto a azerbaiyán contra
los armenios en hago no cara baja y eso
es un hecho
los f-16 los drones turcos están
activamente involucrados en actividades
militares y no militares porque están
bombardeando a los civiles
la pregunta misma de vida del punto
principal más importante que es por qué
está ocurriendo esta guerra
y por qué el lado hacer y no se está
deteniendo cuando la comunidad
internacional está pidiendo un alto el
fuego y le está pidiendo a todo el mundo
que regrese a la mesa de negociaciones
la comunidad internacional también está
presionando a turquía para que se salga
de este conflicto
señor presidente rusia firmó un acuerdo
de seguridad con su país pero también
tiene vínculos con azerbaiyán y usted
habla con vladimir putin que espera de
rusia
primero que todo usted tiene toda la
razón rusia tiene un pacto político
militar con armenia y lo firmamos no por
una razón en especial sino porque rusia
es un aliado y ha sido una aliada de
armenia durante muchos años
rusia ha demostrado históricamente que
las relaciones entre rusia y armenios
son muy importantes para ambas naciones
nos tenemos confianza eso es cierto
segundo rusia también tiene buenas
relaciones con azerbaiyán desde ese
punto de vista y porque cienciano está
directamente involucrado en este
conflicto
a diferencia de turquía rusia puede ser
un mediador imparcial entre las partes y
eso es precisamente lo que rusia está
tratando de hacer con el anuncio y la
decisión política hecha por el
presidente putin y el ministro de
asuntos exteriores lávrov reunión con él
a los dos ministros de exteriores de
armenia y azerbaiyán antes negociaron
durante más de once horas y firmaron un
acuerdo de alto el fuego
al día siguiente el lado hacer y
simplemente lo ignoro eso demuestra una
vez más que el interés de azerbaiyán en
este caso probablemente más el interés
del lado turco no está en armonía con
detener la guerra no está en armonía con
detener los bombardeos a los civiles no
está en armonía con regresar a negociar
y resolver el problema a través de una
vía pacífica
lo más probable es que turquía tenga
planes o ideas muy diferentes y por eso
la presencia del componente turco no
está permitiendo a azerbaiyán continuar
con el alto al fuego cree que debería
haber una intervención militar rusa en
el conflicto señor presidente
primero que todos los armenios han
demostrado en nagorno karabaj e incluso
en la guerra que duró tres años a
principios de los 90 que pueden defender
su país segundo lo que estoy diciendo
aquí no es que se debe involucrar a
rusia y mañana irán y luego otro tercero
y convertir armenia y azerbaiyán y al
cáucaso en otra silla
lo que estoy diciendo es que en vez de
hablar sobre involucrar a rusia debemos
hablar sobre excluir a turquía que tiene
un papel completamente destructivo aquí
está desestabilizando todo el asunto la
añadió una nueva dimensión a esto que no
tiene nada que ver con las aspiraciones
de las personas de nagorno karabaj que
son vivir libremente en su patria tener
su religión
se convirtieron en armenios cristianos
en el año 301 no existían azerbaiyán y
turquía quieren seguir protegiendo su
territorio su familia pero turquía tiene
un acercamiento distinto y otras ideas y
esas ideas no sólo están relacionadas
con la corno karabaj son también
mensajes para armenia para los armenios
en todo el mundo y también para europa
to europe
cree entonces que el grupo de minsk
sigue siendo el marco indicado para
negociar que espera de francia o de
europa a gran escala porque ya mencionó
a europa
analicemos brevemente primero porque
turquía está haciendo esto
afirma que son hermanos éticos de
azerbaiyán pero son hermanos étnicos de
muchas naciones muy lejanas de turquía
segundo hablaron sobre combatientes del
pkk que no tiene ningún sentido hablaron
sobre proteger la infraestructura o los
oleoductos que van desde azerbaiyán a
través de georgia hasta turquía otro
sinsentido
si los armenios tuvieran alguna
intención de atacar esas estructuras lo
habían hecho hace años hace 20 años
impidiéndoles azerbaiyán gana miles de
millones de euros y luego gastarlos en
comprar armas y ahora en matar a los
armenios lo más probable es que la
verdadera intención y esto no lo digo
sólo yo sino muchos otros es que turquía
quiere estar en azerbaiyán quiere
quedarse en azerbaiyán y controlar la
energía si vemos lo que está pasando
desde hace varios años o turquía está
tratando de controlar los recursos
energéticos del mar caspio y de asia
central eso va a europa y de cierta
manera convierte a europa al menos al
sur de europa en un rey como ha ocurrido
con los refugiados señor presidente se
nos está acabando estiren la comunidad
internacional
nagorno karabaj esto muy control volveré
a sus preguntas
rápidamente señor presidente nagorno
karabaj tomó el control de siete
localidades en azerbaiyán durante los
años 90 que se convirtieron en una zona
tapona podría esta zona tapón ser parte
de las negociaciones
estoy hablando sobre las negociaciones
señor presidente que pone sobre la mesa
muy brevemente
se lo diré brevemente el consejo de
seguridad de las naciones unidas se va a
reunir
espero que después de eso hagan un
anuncio presionando a turquía para que
deje de estar involucrado espero que la
otan la unión europea presione la
turquía y azerbaiyán para que se
detengan y empiecen un alto el fuego
llegar a un alto el fuego y que todo
esté sobre la mesa era el objetivo de
tener al grupo de minsk con tres
copresidentes negociando negociando todo
lo que usted dijo las siete regiones las
cinco regiones y eventualmente lo más
importante es la situación final de
nagorno karabaj
todas en la mesa para negociar pero hay
un paso muy simple que hay que dar para
la guerra sentarse en la mesa de
negociación muchas gracias señor
presidente y gracias a ustedes por
sintonizar que deseen france24 para más
información
y
[Música]